[Music]
so the whole diorama took us about three
months to deal in total we use 84 base
plates so it's a 3.6 meters long 1.6
meters wide about 150 000
bricks or parts two different deals so
we have on the left side here is the
jurassic world
and the right side here is the
uh back to the future
so whole concept of this is like a new
research facility for jurassic world
so we start here so this is the research
center
then from here you can see they have
their new jurassic mac okay this is
actually the new lego game velociraptor
cage
we really like a lot of dinosaurs here
we spam as much dinos as we can so the
idea we wanted this is a very dense
forest
so you can see the bottom soil layer
before the grass there's a dinosaur's
hunting on the inside it's the baronics
and see a dilophosaurus
dinosaur tripping down or chasing the
triceratops so over here is our
uh mini river and we have the
carnotaurus
and this is from jurassic world where
they're chasing the gyrosphere
easter eggs from all the disney
franchises small toy story racks we have
a convoy so for them
after they do a research here they'll
transport the dining sauce up and this
one we t-lone from uh evan's son he
built this car
this is the very first jurassic park
car
first one
[Music]
top project manager oh no
yeah yeah just a small project yeah his
main phrase go big or go home
you can see the mountain is actually
quite
tall enough
coming from the opening scene from
jurassic one
so it is a dr grant
and his assistant is digging for the
velociraptor
skeleton
this is actually the mosquito inside the
ember and from this this is where they
draw the blood to recreate all the
dinosaurs
and this is likely from jurassic world
tree
the scene where the jurassic where the
t-rex actually pushed the
car down over the cliff with him trying
to hold on to the girl after the glass
breaks
okay so if you peel back the mountain
you see on the inside there's a
small
star wars easter egg
so a lot of us like star wars so
we love having the cantina and insect
[Music]
this is the other part of the aroma
whereby it's back to the future with
three scenes back to the future scene
whereby the dog actually i'm trying to
hook up with the cables
and then where martin's go back to
second part of the movie 2015 whereby
martin trying to save his son a scene
whereby
the guys get caught and the police went
into
and arrest them for damaging the crown
tower itself
this will be the part 3 whereby the
building is half built and these are all
the small little details of the diorama
scene itself it started off from the
indians from the american indians and
then transit to the most iconic thing
about the clock tower whereby doctor and
martin took the photo together
and followed by the ending scene whereby
they have the families together visit
visiting
martin itself
so there's a lot of small little details
that we have made in the diorama whereby
stranger things he is being put upside
down in the concept of that lego set was
been created in the upside down version
in 1955 there are all the
show play which is very popular and this
is one of the diorama scene whereby the
orange is being pushed by the tree
and we have some friends for some
decoration
and this is martin from back to the
future part one whereby he was wearing
the hazmat shirts
and this is one of our mistakes whereby
we use unique kitty faces expression to
do a feature walk okay this is our
dr strange sentence santorum and this is
one of our easter egg 2 this is the
yellow
and orange portal whereby showing about
the time portal coming to the back to
the future and if you look down to this
panel it looks like a lcd panel of the
doctor strange house
well end of the day we want to upon a
good show uh the fact that we can gather
so many resources when people to build
something
and none of us can do it by ourselves
in the fact that we are
doing this as a team i think that's the
best reward
[Music]
you